you
hi everyone is Gerry I have a nice game
to share with you between Asif Bernstein
playing on the wide end and the great
josé raúl capablanca this one was played
many moons ago 1914 and is a game I
recall first reviewing as an amateur
player and being drawn to it primarily
for the final tactical move only later
revisiting this game as a much more
experienced player master level player
did I acquire a far greater appreciation
for it primarily because of the great
explanation kappa blanka gives to a
particular move new idea or train of
thought one that would have an influence
on future chess greats such as Bobby
Fischer
so in short as an amateur the final
tactical move overshadowed the wonderful
explanation given by kappa blanka to a
particular move so let's dive in and see
how this one plays out and well let's
see how this one strikes you d 4 by
Bernstein the chess machine replying
with a d5 we have a Queens gambit
declined and ok the minor pieces are
flying out black going forward with a
queen side fianchetto a slight change in
the structure and now Queen to a4 this
is preparing a light square bishop
exchange white is already anticipating a
structural shift white is anticipating
in eventual hanging pawns structure a d5
c5 structure and typically when playing
against the hanging pawns you do well to
seek peace exchanges and that's usually
a good way to show that the hanging
pawns are a liability
so that's what we have LightSquared
Bishop is gonna see five white goes
forward with an additional minor piece
exchange a bit of a debatable move as
white is giving up the bishop for night
but okay after D take C B take C this is
where we stand hanging pawn structure
these guys will require the support of
the black pieces and we're also working
with two minor pieces of piece
castles Queen b6
white has no interest in the Queen
exchange you could go for this but
apparently did not want to even allow
the rook to see along the a file so
instead white ducks Queen to e2 and now
here's this new idea by kappa blanka
this new move
see for this you know immediately as
soon as I see that c4 move I think you
just gave light that d5 square but there
are also positives connected with this
c4 move and I do best at this point to
simply share Kappa Blancas explanation
for the move c4
he says White's plan from the start was
to work against the weakness of blacks
hanging C&D puns which must be defended
by pieces the general strategy for such
positions is for whites rooks to occupy
the C and D files attacking blacks
hanging puns while blacks rooks defend
these pawns from the rear the awkward
position of blacks Bishop at7 rendered
it useless except for the purpose of
defending the pawn on c5 it is against
such strategy on the part of light that
the text moves c4 is directed by it the
defensive bishop becomes an attacking
piece since the long diagonal is open to
him and what is more important whites be
pawn is fixed and weakened and becomes a
source of worry for white who has to
defend it also with pieces and thus
cannot use those pieces to attack the
black hanging pawns the fact that the
texts move opens the d4 square for one
of the white knights is of small
consequence since if white posts a
knight there his attack on blacks d5
pawn is blocked for the moment and thus
black has time to assume the offensive I
just find that to be a wonderful
explanation
and this idea this train of thought had
an impact on as mentioned Bobby Fischer
he's not the only one but I've included
in the description to this video a
wonderful game that supplements very
well Kappa Blancas explanation here
regarding the hanging pawns in this c4
move so feel free to check that out
especially if you happen to be a chess
instructor reviewing this video right
now and you want to discuss the hanging
pawn structure this is a must this is
definitely something to share so
continuing here we have
exactly this pressure against d5
it's defended Knight to d4 so as kappa
blanka pointed out you could post a
piece on d4 but now there's less worry
about defending the d5 point directly so
it's like you could do one of the two
but not both at the same time you can
either occupy Defour with the knight or
attack a d5 directly with the rook but
not both meanwhile this B pond has some
pressure on it it's a bit more of a
static point and well also also kappa
blanka pointed out that the bishop can
now become an attacking piece with c4
now and he has a couple options he's
exerting pressure on the c3 Knight b3 is
the follow-up rook on a to c8 shop
choppin now we have a passed pawn C pawn
this is an equal position but yeah it's
white it has to be a bit more careful
and black already having this passed
pawn and there's this four versus three
majority that white has but this
definitely is something that white white
is focused on right now how do how to
make sure that this guy doesn't get out
of control
Bishop takes Knight rook takes now
Knight to d5 c3 just two steps away rook
to see one in trick to c5 this is an
even position and there's a little bit
of back and forth right here and now
this is where White is kind of going in
the wrong direction Knight to b5 rook to
c5 and Knight takes pawn is a serious
blunder as we will soon see better for
white at this stage is to simply return
to the d4 square and come up with
something else
sneaked in a flight square soon
hopefully but yeah at this stage white
goes straight in for this capture of the
pawn which allows this final tactical
sequence this final key blow in the
position and it follows with Knight
takes Knight rook takes Knight rook
takes rook rook takes rook and quick pop
quiz to you there's just one move black
plays from this position and white
throws in the towel and this is a
position I believe multiple tactics
books yeah they share this position and
yeah it's a really good one so if you'd
like to go ahead pause the video what
would you play here as black
okay there is wealth really for both
sides a an issue with the back rank
neither side has a flight square after
Kappa Blancas move 29 Queen - B - that's
the ball game
white throws in the towel why well Queen
takes Queen runs into mate
what other variations to consider clean
here defending the rook allows Queen
takes rook and mate right around the
corner just two other quick variations
Queen - well let's try this one first
rook c2 can be met with queen bee one
and then you simply pick up the rook and
then soon the Queen and lastly if let's
say Queen c2 couple of good things to do
you could take the Queen and if she's
taken back give mate or you could simply
force mate after Queen to c2 with Queen
a1 and after the Queen block we play
rook d1 and that's going to be mate so
as mentioned I thought that as an
amateur player this was really cool but
only later as a much more experienced
player did I have a much greater
appreciation for that little dialogue
that little explanation regarding the
hanging pawns and that key c4 move so
anyhow feel free as usual to leave any
feedback to this one let me know what
your thoughts are and I will catch you
in the next video that's all for now
take care bye
you